a bit of a theme tonight uh it started
with Kate and we were talking about
being uncomfortable uh you know around
your parents or being comfortable
uncomfortable with sexual matters your
show hello ladies um there are you talk
about some things that are a little uh
raw intimate intimate thank you I prefer
your word it's classier um how are your
parents with this show do have your
parents seen the show well they did they
came and I told them that they couldn't
tell me when they were going to come to
the show so they snuck in of undercover
of Darkness um I do I don't talk
entirely about you know sex but I do
discuss it particularly because I'm you
may have noticed a very tall man yes and
it's incredibly difficult the love
making when you're 6' 7 yeah I'm 6' 7
which is too big for because in the UK
the average lady is
5'4 I know which is how T are you you
I'm about 6 4ish somewhere so like so if
you lost like if you stand up for a
second and you just come around here if
you lost like 10 if you lost like a if
you lost like a like what how if you if
you knelt down okay is that
like that's
like that's sort of about that's sort of
about
5'4 there and so like if we were going
to make I would never do it stood up um
but you know like there that's that's
I'm I'm being a bit generous but um like
like if I wanted to make I'd have to
sort of limbo
in you know
to see you see you can see the problem
it's it's you can see the trouble we'd
have it would be this is you know this
is this is some of their I wasn't done
so oh you're
right stop trying to Usher me out you
know that's some people's Ultimate
Fantasy what just happened extraordinary
I like that I was a British a little
British lady in that for scenario the
trouble that I have so consequently I
you know I talk about that in the show
and um and and my parents did come to
say and we never we didn't mention it
afterwards we didn't mention that I
talked about sex that wasn't discussed
um we've never you were mentioning to
Kate about that you know you never talk
about no no we don't talk about those
things in my house I have never
discussed sex with my parents they don't
know as far as I'm concern they don't
know that I know about it they never
they didn't tell me the facts of life we
it's just never been discussed and it's
one of those problem I don't know if you
ever have this where like if you're
watching a movie that has a sex scene in
it with your parents with your parents
yes it's the most intense situation like
I I always try and Screen films ahead of
time to check that they're safe we watch
a lot of Animation you know um but I I
remember watching that movie Atonement
you know that film atonement which is it
was like a classy Oscar winner I thought
there's going to be no filth in this
right right and I'm watching it with my
parents and it's going Grant they're
enjoying they're loving the movie and
we're just in the in the living room and
then uh uh the two stars mavo and and um
Kira nightly go into the library
together alone I'm thinking here we go
oh what's going to happen here and
you're you're with with your folks like
this they were like on the me in a chair
and them on the couch like this there
and Kier nightly and then they start
kissing I'm thinking this just leave now
Kira leave walk out of the library
there's no more nothing more to see here
yes and then um they start getting a
little intimate like we just then and it
starts getting and then the noises
start and I have this
technique and I have this technique
which is to not is to sort of draw to
comment on something in the movie that
shows I'm not in the least bit
interested in the sex do you know what I
mean like so they're in a library
leaning against a bookcase and
they're and I'm just I just I just
watching I went that is a lovely
bookcase that's a wonderful bookcase
that's what do you think that's made of
and my dad what was happening and he's
like that looks like a Rosewood of some
kind
St I tell you he got a bookcase like
that mom um do you remember Pete Harris
from school he's got he's got a book
like and um and uh at this point my
grandmother W my I got like an elderly's
like 75 and she can barely walk and she
came into the room and we're there and
it's and just the folks and she just
came in and she just just saw us there
just looked at us kind of looked at the
sex and just walked out again didn't say
anything
just it was so
bizarre